the stories that get the most attention
online by Design are the most egregious
ones yes they're the ones that are the
least representative because a guy went
out to get milk and he came back and he
found his wife in bed with the postman
and the postman's dog and now she's
taken everything he's worth and his left
leg and he's got gluten intolerance and
he lives underneath a bridge that's the
story that we'll catch because it's
insane but people who don't spend enough
time in the real world live most of
their life vicariously through the
internet so what do they think about the
real world and this is why I don't think
you're a big fan of touching grass
exactly like I can't touch grass people
going out and touching grass really is a
great redress to this I really want to
try and nudge this in the other
direction I've come up with this idea of
toxic positivity which is trying to see
the white pill in everything for every
person that thinks that the world is
ruined there is an opportunity to
separate yourself out from everybody
else that thinks the world is ruined and
the bar's never been set lower that's a
good way to put it